INCLUDING EVERYONE, INCLUDING
HIMSELF AND HIS FAMILY
APPARENTLY.
HE'S ACTUALLY DOING BETTER THAN
MOST POLITICIANS COULD EVER HOPE
FOR.
THAT'S KIND OF INTERESTING.
IT'S AN EXPERIMENT WE ARE LIVING
THROUGH AT ONCE.
>> Kimberly: AND YOUR
>> Greg: ON FOX NEWS, I WAS IN
THE TOP FOUR CRITICS OF
DONALD TRUMP.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT.
>> IT'S IRRELEVANT NOW.
>> Greg: A LOT OF THEM ARE
GONE NOW.
SEEING NOW, WHO CARES ABOUT
THAT?
>> Kimberly: DANA, WHAT IS
YOUR TAKE?
>> Dana: A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE, IN WASHINGTON,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU WORK FOR A
SITTING PRESIDENT.
WHEN GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS' BOOK
CAME OUT DURING THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION, HE WAS BASICALLY
CUT OFF FROM THEM.
IT WAS A BIG DEAL.
THEY BASICALLY SAID YOU ARE DEAD
TO US.
SCOTT McCLELLAN WROTE THE BOOK
DURING THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION.
I WAS PRESS SECRETARY AT THE
TIME AND I WAS SUPER UPSET.
WASHINGTON LOVES A STORY.
AMERICANS DIG INTO IT.
ONE OF THE THINGS PRESIDENT BUSH
CALLED ME INTO THE OVAL OFFICE
AND SET I HEAR YOU ARE UPSET BUT
I DON'T WANT YOU TO WORRY ABOUT
IT.
I SAID, CAN I THROW YOU UNDER
THE BUS?
HE SAID I WANT YOU TO BELIEVE
ME.
NO ONE IS GOING TO THINK ABOUT
THIS IN TWO WEEKS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
POSITIVE FOR REPUBLICANS AND ONE
THING THAT COULD BE TROUBLE
AHEAD.
THE SEVERING OF TIES BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND STEVE BANNON
IS PROBABLY GOOD FOR CONTINUED
COOPERATION FOR THE TYPE OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS GREG WAS A
LITTLE INTO.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE CONSTANT
PUSHING FROM BANNON, YOU ALLOW
THEM TO WORK TOGETHER.
YOU PROBABLY DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT STEVE BANNON TRYING TO
THE THING I THINK THAT WAS
EYE-OPENING ABOUT THE EXCERPT
GREG IS REFERRING TO IS THAT IN
ANYTHING THAT HAS TO DO WITH
2016, IT WAS BEFORE 2016 AND IT
IS ABOUT MONEY LAUNDERING.
TALKED ABOUT JARED KUSHNER.
IN THE PRESIDENT'S STATEMENT, HE
DOESN'T ADDRESS ANY OF THE
CLAIMS.
HE CALLS HIM A STAFFER.
MATT LAUER ASKED PRESIDENT BUSH
WHEN HIS BOOK CAME OUT, WHY
DIDN'T YOU WRITE ABOUT SCOTT
McCLELLAND?
PRESIDENT BUSH THAT I DIDN'T
THINK IT WAS RELEVANT.
THAT'S THE WAY YOU TRY TO SORT
THIS WILL BE A STORY FOR A
COUPLE DAYS AND MOVE ON.
THE MONEY LAUNDERING PIECE WAS
EYE-OPENING.
>> Kimberly: IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT WENT OUT
OF HIS WAY TO MAKE THESE
STATEMENTS.
KNOWLEDGE, INFORMATION WHERE HE
HAD PROBLEMS WITH BANNON
ET CETERA AND BELIEVES SOME OF
THESE THINGS TO BE OCCURRING IN
THE PAST WHEN HE WAS THERE BUT I
KNOW THEY WERE STILL IN
COMMUNICATION ONCE STEVE BANNON
LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Jesse: I AM SURPRISED HE
DIDN'T SAY I DIDN'T KNOW STEVE
BANNON.
THE STORY IS EITHER FAKE NEWS OR
THE MEDIA SHOT ITSELF IN THE
FOOT AND IF IT'S REAL, BANNON IS
I READ THE FIRST PARAGRAPH.
THREE LIES, TRUMP DIDN'T WANT TO
WIN, MELANIA CRIED AND
KELLYANNE CONWAY DIDN'T THINK
THEY WERE GOING TO WIN.
I KNOW THOSE ARE LIES.
YOU HAVE BANNON SAYING THIS
MEETING AT TRUMP TOWER WAS
TREASONOUS.
ON "60 MINUTES" TWO MONTHS AGO
HE SAID THE COLLUSION THING WAS
A FARCE.
THIS GUY WOLF HAS A TERRIBLE
REPUTATION AND HIS OWN INDUSTRY.
PEOPLE SAY HE IS A GUN FOR HIRE.
LAST BOOK, 12 PEOPLE CAME
FORWARD AND SAID ALL OF THE
QUOTES ATTRIBUTED TO ME WERE
COMPLETELY MANUFACTURED.
>> Kimberly: HE TALKED TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: HE'S GOT A
REPRESENTATION
REPUTATION FOR INVENTING THINGS
OUT OF THIN AIR.
IF STEVE BANNON SAID THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
SUN AS A TRAITOR AND WEAK AND
COULD CRACK AND HIS SON-IN-LAW
TRUMP VALUES LOYALTY ALMOST
ABOVE EVERYTHING.
PREVIEWED OFF THE RECORD.
IF THIS IS TRUE, HE HAS NO
CREDIBILITY GOING INTO THE
PRIMARIES WHICH I THINK IS GOING
THAT COULD HELP THE PRESIDENT.
>> Geraldo: I TAKE IT ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL.
IN TERMS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROSPECTS, DANA ASTUTELY LAID
OUT THE IMPACT.
THE FACT THAT BANNON IS IN
EXILE.
ET TU, BRUTE?
YOU TALK ABOUT TREASON?
STEVE BANNON, HOW DARE HE.
THE BEST DEFENSE FOR
DONALD TRUMP JR. IN THE INFAMOUS
MEETING IN THE WHITE HOUSE, NOT
BEING NEFARIOUS, IT WAS SO NAIVE
THERE WAS NO LAWYER THERE.
SO OVEREAGER, OVERENTHUSIASTIC.
TO ME, THAT'S HIS BEST DEFENSE.
DONALD JR. DIDN'T INTEND TO
COLLUDE WITH RUSSIANS IN ANY WAY
THAT WAS ILLEGAL ANYWAY.
HE WANTED TO GET WHATEVER
INFORMATION HE COULD GET.
>> Kimberly: DO YOU BELIEVE HE
THING STEVE BANNON DID IN THIS
WHOLE EPISODE IS TO SUGGEST
STRONGLY THAT DONALD TRUMP JR.
IS SITTING IN TRUMP TOWER A
SURROUNDED BY THESE COMMIES.
AND THEN AFTER THE MEETING HE
SAYS THERE WAS ZERO POSSIBILITY
HE DIDN'T TAKE THE RUSSIANS UP
TO SEE HIS FATHER.
"WASHINGTON POST,"
"NEW YORK TIMES," EVERY
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER IN THE
NATION HAS BEEN STRIVING TO
CONNECT DONALD TRUMP WITH THAT
MEETING WITH THE RUSSIANS AND
HAS FAILED TO DO SO.
NOW HERE'S STEVE BANNON
SUGGESTING YOU CAN TAKE IT TO
THE BANK.
ZERO PROBABLY          PROBABILI
ZERO PROBABLY          PROBABILY
ZERO PROBABLY          PROBABILD
ZERO PROBABLY          PROBABIL'
ZERO PROBABLY          PROBABILT
ZERO PROBABLY          PROBABILH
ZERO PROBABLY          PROBABILP
ZERO PROBABLY          PROBABILE
ZERO PROBABLY          PROBABILN
ZERO PROBABLY          PROBABIL.
THIS GUY WAS HIS BEST FRIEND?
>> Kimberly: IT'S
DISCONCERTING IF SOMEBODY WAS
ADVISING HIM, TRYING TO
TRANSFORM AMERICAN POLITICS AND
THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, YOU DON'T DO
IT BY MAKING THESE KIND OF VERY
STRONG STATEMENTS AND TAKING A
SWIPE AND TRYING TO TAKE OUT THE
PRESIDENT SON AND THE FAMILY AND
THE ESSENTIALLY THE PRESIDENT
AND THE MEDIA A WEAPON TO HER
THE PRESIDENT WITH.
A LOT OF THE SAME PEOPLE HAVE
SAID STEVE BANNON IS THIS
HORRIBLE PERSON, HE'S RACIST,
PROPAGANDA.
A TRUTH TELLER.
THEY ARE USING THIS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
IT IS SAD, THE WHOLE THING IS
SAD AND HE DIDN'T NEED TO
HAPPEN.
>> Geraldo: ONE QUICK POINT.
GREG SUGGESTED PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID THIS ON A LARK.
I'VE KNOWN HIM A LONG TIME.
HE STARTED TELLING ME HE WAS
HE WANTED TO BE PRESIDENT MORE
THAN HE WANTED TO MAKE MONEY.
>> Greg: I BELIEVE HE HAD
DOUBTS, THE WAY EVERYBODY HAD
DOUBTS.
AS FOR BANNON, I BELIEVE HE
HATED THE FAMILY BECAUSE THE
FAMILY PROVIDED INSULATION FROM
BANNON.
THOSE WERE THE ONLY PEOPLE IN
THIS WAY.
I THINK BANNON SAW TRUMP AS A
VESSEL FOR HIS OWN DISRUPTIVE
PRINCIPLES AND AGENDA.
HE WANTED TO DISRUPT.
>> Kimberly: HE DIDN'T LIKE
THE GLOBALIST TENDENCIES.
>> Greg: BANNON IS A RADICAL.
HE WANTS TO DISRUPT.
HE DOESN'T HAVE MILD OPINIONS.
EVERY OPINION IS THE EXTREME
OPINION.
WHO EMBRACED ROY MOORE?
BANNON.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.